oh hey mom hey dad my mom my dad my mom
my dad hey mom hey Dad
autumns in the air and you know what
that means I'm coming home for the
holidays Thanksgiving Christmas New
Year's sleeping in my old bed again
catching up just being together as a
family again
it would be a shame if something were to
come up to ruin that like let's say
Trump being elected president Trump
being elected president according to the
Atlantic 90% of his supporters are white
and you guys are really white super
white I just needed to make sure that
you're not voting for him you're not
voting for him if Trump were elected
president I'd be pretty upset he
believes some crazy things some weird
things like that climate change is a
hoax invented by the Chinese and that
Obama founded Isis and that the election
is rigged and that Donald Trump is a
good businessman you know things that
used to be crazy to believe you know
like how it's okay for a famous man to
grab a woman by her [ __ ] our president
a schlub who thinks it's okay to grab me
by my [ __ ] think about that Dad my
[ __ ] or mom's [ __ ] yeah you know how
hard that was for me to save mom's [ __ ]
so I'll probably not be leaving my home
like ever again I I don't even know if I
couldn't come home thinking about
president Trump president Trump grabbing
mom's [ __ ] if Trump were in the White
House do you think he would have to go
door-to-door around the neighborhood
thing hi I'm a registered sex offender
no you wouldn't shame shame shame so I'm
not surprised if I'm jogging and I'm
running past the White House and the man
that lives there happens to grab my
[ __ ] dad my [ __ ] mom's [ __ ] if Trump
is elected this year I'm having a
friendsgiving wouldn't that be a shame
if you guys voted for Trump and I just
couldn't come home for the holidays
anymore
of us want that guys want that do we do
we do we so on November 8th think about
how badly you want to see me these
holidays cuz I want to see you but I
want to see Trump lose even more love
you love you guys okay bye
BYE MOM bye dad who was that
it's Brad he wanted to know if he can
join our family for Thanksgiving another
one yeah it's